I AM SURE THAT WE HAVE
COLLEAGUES ON THE WAY SO WHY
DON'T WE GO AHEAD AND CALL.
THIS.
MEETING OF THE RULES COMMITTEE
TO ORDER MADAM SECRETARY.
SENATORS BATES MINING.
MINING HERE ROTH WILK PRESIDENT
WILK HERE ATKINS HERE ATKINS
HERE.
WE HAVE A QUORUM I WHY DON'T WE
GO AHEAD I ITEM NUMBER.
ONE IS THE ESTABLISHMENT OF THE
SELECT COMMITTEE -- AS IT
RELATES TO THE GOVERNOR'S TWENTY
NINETEEN REPORT ON WILDFIRES IN
CLIMATE CHANGE.
I IT ESTABLISHES THE THIRTEEN I
YOU CAN SEE IT IN PRINT I WOULD
ENTERTAIN A MOTION SO MOVED.
THANK YOU -- YOU WILL GO AND DO
IT THIS WAY WHY DON'T YOU CALL
THE ROLL MADAM SECRETARY
[inaudible]
SENATORS BATES [inaudible]
MONNING.
MONNING AYE ROTH.
WILK HI WILK AYE ATKINS HI
ATKINS I AM SECRETARY LEAVE THE
ROLE OPEN -- LET'S GO AHEAD AND
I CAN TAKE A MOTION ON FLOOR
ACKNOWLEDGMENTS.
ITEMS TWO THROUGH.
SEVEN THANK YOU MISTER VICE
CHAIRMAN -- CALDERON.
SENATORS FATES MINING.
MONNING AYE ROTH.
WILK AYE WILK AYE ATKINS AYE
ATKINS AYE AYE AND AS WE ARE
CALLING THE ROLE THIS IS ITEM
FLOOR KNOWLEDGE INSIDE AND TWO
THROUGH.
SEVEN SENATOR ROTH.
THANK YOU BUT ROTH I OKAY.
WE WILL ARE THAT THAT PASSES FOR
FOUR ZERO WITHIN ABSENCE.
I'LL GO AHEAD AND LIFT THE CALL
ON ITEM NUMBER ONE THE SELECT
COMMITTEE.
APPOINTMENTS.
SENATORS BATES ROCK.
ROUGH BY THAT YES IS FOUR ZERO
WITH ONE ABSENCE THANK YOU.
WE'RE GONNA GO INTO EXECUTIVE
SESSION
MADAM SECRETARY -- MOTION.
THANK YOU MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL SENATORS BATES
BATES HI MONNING.
MONNING AYE ROTH ROTH AYE WILK
HI WILK I ATKINS HI A CONCISE.
FIVE ZERO THAT IS UNANIMOUS AND
COLLEAGUES THANK YOU SO MUCH WE
ARE NOW ADJOURNED